let's talk a little bit about the rise
of chess in Asia and we'll start with
China move over to India what happened
in China how come they started
dominating world Women's World
Championships yeah I mean it's really
interesting and if you think about it I
think it's more over the last decade or
so because before that we didn't you
know it wasn't it wasn't that strong I
think what's really changed is just the
fact that their infrastructure and their
way of working from grassroot level is
so it's so powerful you know they they
find talent at a very young age they
bring them in there they train them boys
and girls are working together from a
young age they're preparing together
they're training together so the idea is
never to become a strong woman chess
player but just to become a really
strong chess player and just to talk
about that nurturing because I went to
Beijing and I visited the Chinese chess
Association and they have this building
in central Beijing which serves as a
dormitory a canteen a cafeteria a
library and chest trainers we're
literally just as you have said there's
a training classroom program for boys
and girls yes so it's like a chess
school and it starts from a really young
age so I think it's more than
infrastructure which is which there's a
lot to learn from really because often
many countries is focused on you know
girls playing in with other girls and
boys thing with other boys and
participating in the under eights and
the under 9s and the under tens but I
think that's never been their focus and
that's never been their priority which
is also why you might see that there are
not so many Chinese world junior
champions for example or because it's
just something that I think they just
they just focus so much on the big
picture and you're not trying to create
like players who are just overall strong
chess players and the way they do it is
very different from the rest of the
world and over the last ten years that's
shown massive results the other big
thing that I think is so important for
all countries is to have tournaments you
know
yes they invite they invite players
you've got China versus the rest of the
world happening they've got leagues
happening
they've got women tournaments they've
got tournaments where with mixed teams
and we don't even there are most of
these tournaments we don't even see or
hear about but they're always going on
there and they're constant I'm simply on
right
compare that with your own experience in
India yeah that's interesting yes
because you know when I was growing up
and when I started playing chess I come
from Delhi at that time whatever chess
was in the country was in the South
Chennai from wherever she is from and
never barely any girls I mean I was the
only one from north of India so it was
it was really hard I had to travel a lot
and I had to you know it was hard to get
training and things like that but that's
really really evolved and change now and
I think again that's because there's
this big boom of chess in general and
women chess as well you know we've got
tournaments now we've got support now
there are players who are performing and
winning medals and I think that's the
key point the thing is that when when
you've got you got people winning yes
you have more people who want to win
exactly so when you see kids who are
young and we're winning medals for the
country who are performing well you'll
automatically have kids at brass root
level wanting to be chess players right
and that's what's happening in India as
well we don't the one thing that I
really miss in India and I would really
want it to happen is the Chess League we
don't have that there is a Chinese
league obviously in Europe they have a
lot of European there's no Indian Lee no
there isn't and that's something that I
think that is that just because of the
country itself it's huge geography or
something I mean the players really want
it and we'll see what happens we also
have a new Federation now the All India
Chess Federation and there's a lot of
positive changes that are being made so
hopefully this will also be one of them
the other thing I think which is really
important which I think in the US has
really changed the game is actually
making it a profitable option you know
to play in the national championships
and for players to feel that when
they're playing there is good money to
be made and the hard work that they're
putting in they're getting the returns
for that
that's slowly evolving I mean five or
ten years ago you know playing in the
national championships of playing
national tournaments was just just as
nothing fun in it for players right
and now as that changes you see more and
more things coming in well let's talk
about your own professionalism for a
second like how did it evolve in your
case that you became a chess
professional because you consider
yourself a chess professional so how did
you be what was that breakthrough that
occurred in your life Tanya that's that
okay now I'm a chess professional you
know it's interesting but I think it was
there was it's hard to kind of pinpoint
a certain moment I feel it was more like
a journey okay but if I if I really
think about it I think making it to the
national team was the moment I was
crucial it was crucial because you know
then then you really know that this is
this is what you want the feeling the
rush the whole scenario of representing
your country I mean it right it was when
I was graduating from school and I had
to decide if I wanted to get into you
know studies academics university or I
wanted to pursue my chess and and then I
went to play the Asian women
championship in Iran okay and I want
that and you know just the feeling of if
you're not yes
yes and winning and I think that's the
crucial point I think the more you win
the more you want to win so over the
years it just it just became something
it just felt really cool to be a chess
player you know yeah you you were not
it's not a job it's really really
difficult chess is a really difficult
game it is no guarantees no guarantees
I'm just a game itself is so tough I
mean it Dan but I feel like that's the
reason we play it if it was easy nobody
would play chess mm-hmm it's a hard game
and I think there are many roadblocks
and and I think the biggest thing that
we as chess players professional players
really have to go through our bad
tournaments oh yeah those are real
activism by fire there's this nothing
fun about it is it no there's nothing
fun and everybody's gonna have a bad
turn everybody's gonna have it and I
mean even the topless all the time right
right I think the one I think the one
thing that that I really feel
is that there's really not been a better
time to be a professional chess player
than right now with the kind of
opportunities that are there whether
you're a boy or a girl right
you know if there's this whole other
topic about how chess is such a great
sport to get into because it's its use
development for your mind and the skills
translate and transfer into whatever you
do and make you the best version of
yourself but even to try and become a
professional chess player I mean the
sheer number of opportunities that you
have the tournaments that you have the
sponsors the sponsorships that are
coming in I mean this is the golden
period for chess no question about it I
feel very strongly the same way I mean
when you just throw in the grand chest
for what you have been also mentioning
about the fee date the improvement of
the cycles the internet itself and you
know like and the prize money it's
getting getting better but I really
wanted to ask you what was your biggest
stumbling blocks like man you couldn't
become a master or you couldn't win the
Indian Championship what were your
biggest stumbling blocks and did you
break through I mean for me personally
it's been becoming a Grand Master
exactly I've got doom Grand Master noms
I need one more and I need a reason yes
I need my first Grandmaster Nam in 2009
and my second in 2016 what are you
waiting for
maybe another nine years no it's not
that
no it's I mean it's something that's
been you know my my aim in chess and the
other thing that I've been really uh
that's what you want yes but I also
realize like there's no point putting
pressure on myself at least like where I
am right now in my career and my
professional life we'll see what happens
but my idea is to constantly improve and
to try and improve but yes there was a
time when I felt really frustrated with
that not happening okay but I think what
you have to realize is that you can't be
that hard on yourself and you know you
all you really have to do is try your
best and that's really all you can do I
sue I remember when I used to have a bad
game I used to feel extremely I couldn't
eat I couldn't sleep
I used to be really really difficult
exactly and then and often it would
happen you make the thing with chest is
that you can have a really good game and
then you make one bad move and it all
goes down and then you're like why am i
why my weakness why am I even alive like
what what am i right and it's really
hard to deal with those moments but then
my I remember my trainer he told me that
he said you know you you can't be hard
on yourself for like making bad moves
because chess is so hard and so
difficult that that's gonna happen it's
you are always gonna make mistakes right
but what you have to be hard on yourself
and what you shouldn't be forgiving
about is having a bad attitude so you
need to see where you're going wrong and
if you're not
after realizing why you're going wrong
or what you're doing if you're not
really working on it I know if you're
not really trying to improve that that's
something that you need to look into but
you shouldn't feel bad about losing a
game and I think I have a feeling and
this is out of pure experience and I
could be totally not wrong that women
players and girls actually take losing
worse than then the boys do insist
something that I learn a lot from my
friends from you know the Indian men
team and and all my other friends I feel
like we're a little more emotional about
it and and as girls we tend to get we
take it a bit harder while while the
boys take it as a sport they take it is
like a you know yeah we messed up I'll
tell you I'll share my thought on the
subject with you it comes these words of
wisdom come from Graciela casillas who
is a woman's world champion kickboxer
and boxer and she said learn to love her
me learn to love the training and all
goals are possible and that's a true
langar you gas proves that hard work is
a skill it's a talent you know